vie locale le projet des fresques du
vélib ou qui suit son cours hier
après-midi avait lieu une réunion à la
maison des familles la mosaïque de
plaisir pour présenter les premières
réalisations artistiques et les
démarches créatives
rappelons que huit façades d'immeubles
seront décorés elles ont été choisies en
fonction de leurs positions stratégiques
afin que les fresques soit visible par
le plus grand nombre
si tes créations qui est en charge du
projet s'est inspiré des témoignages des
photos et des demandes envoyées par les
habitants ce qui ressortit beaucoup
c'est la diversité des couleurs à la
profusion des couleurs la profusion
aussi des rythmes d énergie on a eu
beaucoup de mots ni beaucoup
d'interviews au delà des échanges
voilà dans le cadre de ses ateliers avec
les habitants on a eu beaucoup de vidéos
qui nous ont été transmises on a eu des
comptes on a eu des témoignages des
histoires plein de photos donc on a
essayé de ceux de s'imbiber tout ça est
un moment pour faire notre travail
d'artiste de designers artistes peintres
il faut qu on s'extrait de tout ça pour
se projeter
prochain rendez vous en juin lors du
festival escales d'ailleurs cité à
création présentera les skis sous forme
de maquette à tous les habitants de
plaisir le début des travaux ce sera
pour la fin de l'année 2016 nous